why do you think he's not using his own
money to pay for his legal fees because
he's the cheapest person I've ever met
in my life
that's why and and what he's very good
at Caitlyn is spending other people's
money right and if you look at his
history in New Jersey do you think he's
misleading vote his voters his
supporters by uh I think those
supporters you know write a check to
Trump for president they think they're
paying for campaign expenses not for
personal legal expenses now in Trump's
defense I don't even know that it's a
trump defense there are cultists so deep
in the cult that they are glad to pay
for Trump's legal defense because they
believe that the indictments are
political that it's actually Joe Biden
doing it and all these different things
so like there I I think Chris Christie
is right that there are some Trump
donors who think the money is being used
for the campaign there are some who know
it's being used for the legal defense
and are fine with that and there are
those who are in this position where
they believe that the legal defense is
kind of part of the campaign